ils font partie du paysage
partout en alberta dans chaque petite
fille presque on retrouve un poste de
police de la gendarmerie royale du
canada c'est le cas ici un pinscher
quick pas très loin frontière américaine
par un froid matin de janvier ils sont
une vingtaine de résidents de la
communauté à se déplacer pour écouter ce
qu'a à dire le cesi 4 il représente les
agents
la fédération de la police nationale est
en tournée pour mettre en garde les
algues vertes est contre l'idée d'une
police provinciale coûts plus élevés et
recrutement difficile ou encore temps de
réponse aux urgences pas nécessairement
plus rapide des arguments convaincants
pour ses résidents qu'ils ne veulent pas
voir non plus la grc être remplacé
après ce premier arrêt de la journée
direction red bull est maintenant pour
la prochaine assemblée
en deux mois la fédération de la police
nationale aura répété l'exercice dans
une trentaine de villes partout en
alberta un tournée convaincre mais aussi
pour écouter les albertains en milieu
rural on se préoccupe de la qualité des
services offerts par la grc
et plus d'agents pourrait en effet être
embauchés admis quévenois le directeur
régional du syndicat se décrit d'abord
et avant tout comme un fier à liberté
qui a fait toute sa carrière à la grc
dans la province il selon lui c'est le
gouvernement albertain veut mieux servir
les communautés rurales il n'a qu'à
embaucher plus d'agents de la grc une
solution beaucoup moins dispendieuse que
de créer un nouveau corps policiers
parce qu'il est vrai que remplacer la
grc coûterait cher aux libertés avec un
coût estimé entre 7 135 et 759 millions
$ une police provinciale coûterait
annuellement un peu moins cher que le
modèle actuel dont la facture totale
s'élève à environ 7 183 millions de
dollars sauf que l'alberta perdrait les
quelques 185 millions de dollars annuels
versés par le fédéral qu'ils payent 30%
des coûts la grc à cela s'ajouterait
aussi une somme de 366 millions $ pour
faire la transition entre la grc et une
police provinciale
malgré la facture le gouvernement kenny
soutient que l'idée mérite d'être
explorée encore davantage en noir
comme en ontario et au québec un service
provincial rendre l alberta plus
autonomes souci le gouvernement kenny la
province d'alberta le président du fcn
répond que la province importance déjà
toute la latitude pour gérer comme il le
veut les opérations de la grc sur son
territoire les décisions de priorité de
combattre les drogues
saviez
ici peut être là le coeur de l'enjeu
en tissant du canada la grc demeure une
présence fédéral est un symbole canadien
fort après un référendum sur la
péréquation le projet de police
provinciale s'inscrit dans une démarche
autonomiste de l'alberta explique ce
professeur ça fait partie de la même
veine ça fait parti d'un courant de fond
qui est qui et qui tu qu'ils ont c'est
pas nouveau et dans le fond que ni fait
juste reprendre et fait juste mettre en
mots dans un programme politique les
doléances qui sont déjà là depuis très
longtemps une façon aussi pour un
premier ministre plus populaire de
solidifier ses appuis c'est des enjeux
qui sont très importantes la base du
parti unifié conseiller conservateur
unifiée
mais y at il vraiment un désir concrets
de se débarrasser de la grc dans un
grand rapport commandé par jason kenny
seulement 35 % des albertains sondés
estimaient que la création d'une police
provinciale donnerais tu à la province
une meilleure place dans la fédération
canadienne de toutes les suggestions
autonomiste du fair deal panneaux celle
de remplacer la grc demeurer l'une des
moins populaire
de nombreuses municipalités ne sont pas
convaincus elle non plus qu'il fallait
remplacer la grc
très heureux de la relation entre sa
communauté rurale et la grc toriques un
bon on ne voit pas d'un bon oeil cette
idée de créer une police provinciale
le gouvernement liberté tiendra bientôt
ses propres assemblée publique et
lancera également un sondage ce n'est
qu'après ce processus qu'on saura si
l'alberta ira de l'avant avec son projet
de police provinciale
si la province décidé remplacer le gers
et la transition pourrait prendre
jusqu'à six ans la gendarmerie royale du
canada devrait faire partie du paysage à
liberté pendant encore au moins un
certain temps